grainy footage from inside the durham
miners hall does this phone camera film
show the labour leader working or did
pandemic rules mean it was illegal
socializing
the police investigated and decided no
rules were broken here last april but
after pressure including from tory
cabinet members they've changed stance
after receiving significant new
information the labour leader still
adamant today that the events shown here
involved no rules being broken as i've
explained a number of times we were
working in the office we stopped for
something to eat no party no breach of
the rules the police obviously have got
their job to do we should let them get
on with it but i'm confident that no
rules were broken
we know that the labour leader spent the
day in hull limbering up to fight last
year's set of local elections
he and his campaign team went on to what
he called a working dinner
curry was ordered beer was drunk
yes this is good
that's it
starmer is now the one taking blows
because of the high standards he set in
january calling then for the resignation
of boris johnson at the outset of the
police investigation the reality is that
we now have the shameful spectacle of a
prime minister of the united kingdom
being subject to a police investigation
unable to leave the country
incapable of doing the right thing
and every day his cabinet failed to
speak out they become more and more
complicit
the shadow attorney general suggesting
the investigation is the result of an
improper political campaign i appreciate
they've been put under a lot of pressure
there's lots of people who've been
campaigning for the police to er open
this investigation lots of conservative
mps have been asking lots of the
conservative supporting newspapers have
been making a big fuss about it if
they're opening it again that's fine we
will answer questions
kierstama wanted to spend today doing
this celebrating polling gains instead
the afternoon was spent with the party
discussing whether if he is fined he
must quit not the ending to the
partygate election anyone could have
expected sam coates sky news westminster